for the past couple of months the
Russian invasion of Ukraine seems to
have slowed down front less solidified
or move that glacial speeds where even a
smaller Village Changing Hands was big
news however this may be about to change
the war in Ukraine is likely entering
another turning point in the form of the
much awaited Ukrainian summer
counter-offensive let's take a look at
what this means for Putin's Invasion and
whether it can bring the end of the war
closer and we'll be doing this in the
usual presentation format of our Lord
and savior Peru
recently visually confirmed heavy
equipment losses for Russia have
exceeded 10 000 according to ordex this
is an absolutely insane number for
example Russians have lost about six
times more tanks than the entire active
German tank Fleet according to
pro-russian commentators though this
should not be an issue Russia possesses
a virtually endless stockpile of heavy
equipment therefore despite the
ludicrous losses Ukraine is only
delaying the inevitable this is not true
however let's take tanks as an example
Russia has 20 000 tanks as they say and
if this was true that would mean despite
all those catastrophic losses Russia
would have lost only 10 percent of its
tanks good thing this isn't true we know
this because YouTube user covered cabal
spent months purchasing satellite images
of all Russian tank Depots and then just
counter the tanks and he came up with
the following numbers in 2022 Russia had
4696 tanks that were in good condition
meaning no obvious signs of damage no
missing turret and so on in 2023 this
number sank to 3911 so at this loss rate
according to him Russia will ran out of
tanks in about two years however the
tanks Russia out of storage aren't
getting better or newer it's the
opposite in fact for this reason we've
seen Russians bring out t62 tanks first
introduced in 1961 and over the past
couple of weeks d54 and t55 tanks first
introduced in 1947. now this does not
mean that Russia doesn't have any t-72s
or t80s left what this does mean is
Russia is struggling to push more
Vehicles into service and has to
backfill with such rolling Museum
exhibits but the t-54 and 55 tanks
likely won't be used in a tank roll to
explain this I have with me the one and
only laser Pig author of many famous
video essays including about the t-34
and the T14 armata yes it's me what am I
doing here I just show up I'm everywhere
yesterday I was v-tubing now I'm
collaborating with your favorite doc
YouTuber tomorrow who knows I could be
anywhere you never know where I'm going
to show up you can't stop me what are
you realistically going to do here ah
I've got every angle covered I ain't
screwing around here you throw me to the
Wolves I'll come back pregnant I cannot
be stopped I can only be contained
anywhere Ukraine David 55 started
arriving on the Russian fronts recently
there's a perfectly normal sentence to
say these are tanks which were put into
service back in 1948. it's one of the
most purchased taxes
I'm sorry I'm just thinking about this
the t55 is on the front line
front lights one of the most produced
tanks in history being the Workhorse of
the Soviet Union with just over a
hundred thousand of each Mark in version
built now you might be wondering because
you're a sensible intelligent human
being what on Earth is a tank from 1948
during the modern Battlefield the
equivalent of which would be like
America busting out the M40 patent
during Operation Desert Storm well for
the longest time pretty much all the
military history nerds watching this
conflict were for once in agreement with
each other Russia has started buying
ammunition from Iran a ship was
documented crossing the Black Sea about
a month or so ago now Iran produces a
very nice modern 100 millimeter high
explosive artillery shell very nice
round but Russia doesn't have a lot of
100 millimeter article it does but what
it does have were exceptionally unwieldy
field cannons like the mt-12 which I
know that looks like it's from World War
II but this this it's a modern cannon
from the 70s don't think about it okay
now the problem with guns like these is
they're not very good you know we're
given the train of Ukraine there's
somewhat wet weather that turns the
ground to that famous monster swamped at
every single documentary in World War II
won't shut up about does it stopped
announces any cranes gradually
increasing advantage in counter battery
fire the static arterial like this is
really starting to struggle you see
static artillery is great on the basis
that it's cheap that the crews don't
need much training and all you really
need to do to aim is have one guy who
knows a little bit of math stand on a
hill with a pair of binoculars so you
could afford a lot of it which is
perfect if you're an army with a lot of
Manpower and not a lot of money like
Russia but static RT has a major problem
it's static the longer it stays in
position the more likely it is to
receive counter battery fire and the
more accurate that counter battery fire
is going to become now the Americans
tried to solve this problem by having
their artillery capable of being lifted
and moved by a helicopter the ukrainians
pack it up and move it by truck and can
do it in less than two minutes but the
Russians never trained to do that the
trucks drive in drop the men off who dig
well on transpositions for the guns and
then leave because those same trucks are
needed to Ferry ammunition and supply
sides of the division so they can't
afford to hang around all day waiting
for the guns to decide they want to move
and with the major shortage of logistics
Vehicles Russia's suffering that problem
is only going to get worse static
artillery specially russian-built static
artillery has another problem it's not
particularly precise it's built to be
used on mass with hundreds of other
artillery pieces which you know okay
it's still a viable tactic but it does
waste a lot of ammo it requires a
massive production of output of shells
and a logistics change strong enough to
accommodate it Russia has neither even
before the war their factories were
their maximum production levels Russia
was relying on its near infinite
stockpile and as this war has dragged on
that stockpile has proven to be less
infinite than expected in fact it was
only recently that Russia admitted it
had run out of 122 millimeter shells in
June of last year it's now running low
on 105 and 155 millimeter shells and in
fact it's running solo many Russian
troops were provided with shells that
were so old they had rusted together
good for them compare this to Western
artillery that Ukraine has received
which fires once and hits exactly what
it was aiming at it's expensive but you
don't need as many guns you don't need
as much ammo and you don't need to
replace the barrels so often and that's
another issue Russia as far as we can
tell doesn't seem to be producing
replacement barrels they just take what
they need from stockpiles all of this
has been adding up to an extremely large
headache for Russia that begins and ends
with static artillery there is a price
for making things cheap what Russia
needs is mobile artillery spgs which can
fire and then move without the need of a
valuable tow vehicle now Russia has a
lot of these but well okay here I go
with the pronunciations again the good
sticker is a 122 millimeter which Russia
does not have ammo for and the muster is
a 152.4 and the 2s35 they only have 12
of fun fun so Along Comes Iran now it's
hoping when this war all blows over
Russia would be so thankful for helping
them out that they'll Supply them with
brand new sdu 50 sevens and su-75s so
they can finally take over a rack which
means there might be a future War where
our allies are the Taliban
try not to think about it you just just
just don't just honestly don't now with
Iran supplying these 100 millimeter
shells and Russia in desperate need for
an SPG what it needs is a mobile 100
millimeter gun which doesn't exist but
the t-55 well that has a 100 millimeter
cannon and though it's not ideal using a
tank as standard artillery is something
Russia has trained for and all it needs
is the same crew doing the same stuff as
static artillery but just one of them
needs to learn to drive and the best
thing is if Ukraine does initiate its
fabled expected counter-attack within
the coming months t-55 is though
laughable as a main battle tank can move
faster than static artillery it can
carry troops it can carry its own ammo
and it can survive ambushes from Small
Arms fire so for Russia it's looking
like a win-win except of course nothing
is as simple as it seems with that in
mind a phrase we often hear nowadays is
Ukrainian ammo shortage the West simply
cannot keep up with the rate of
Ukrainian shell consumption resulting in
degraded combat performance Russians
seem to be suffering from the same issue
across most of the front line as showns
are rooted to Priority areas such as
avdivco and bakmud while the rest of the
front has to do with minimal amounts
Soviet stocks seem to have finally run
dry and Russia now has to rely on its
own production also on Iran and North
Korea so this looks like a stalemate
with both sides struggling not a good
omen for a counter-offensive however the
situation actually tilts in Ukraine's
favor why is that turns out if you have
better accuracy you don't need as many
shells if Russians need a hundred shells
to carpet bomb the general area of
Ukrainian artillery then ukrainians only
need a few rounds to get the job done
you do see where this is going a good
example for this is high Mars one
vehicle has one missile pod one missile
pod has six missiles Ukraine has 16
launcher Vehicles if all 16 highways
Vehicles launch two pots per day that's
192 meters per day or 5 800 missiles per
month the rate of manufacturing of those
missiles is 9000 per year at this rate
Ukraine should have ran out of hymers a
year ago but they didn't because they
don't just fire Wireless everything that
moves accuracy helps overcome shown
shortage and Ukrainian Hardware is far
more accurate than Russia's Russia Fires
at everything that moves that City you
live in now it's gone that field that
you may counter-attack on now it's a
hole that special for there now it's
fire again this Cycles back to what I
was talking about earlier Russia has an
artillery fetish because artillery is
cheap and War becomes less costly when
you can force your enemy to retreat by
simply saturating everything it touches
with massive amounts of explosions in
theory and that theory being we live in
a universe where no one has ever thought
about firing back at artillery with
their own artillery this kind of tactic
works extremely well it means that your
enemy can never put up a strong defense
they can never concentrate their forces
because anytime they do in comes the
artillery every bunker every trench
becomes a death trap and every
counter-attack becomes saturated as
explosions go off around you this is the
future War which Russia envisioned and
for the longest time that tactic was
working Ukraine was forced to play
defensive behind his lines unable to
force an effective counter-attack as a
tried the field they were in would
suddenly turn into fire but such a
tactic was never meant to last as long
as it did Russia expected to be parading
through Kiev by now its public
government should be celebrating its
massive totally legit election Landslide
and the whole situation should be fading
from the minds of the western media
distracted as once again some celebrity
has been found in a motel room with a
stripper and their weight in cocaine
instead were on to year 2 of the
three-day special military operation the
army that could supposedly take on the
entirety of Europe while holding back
the Americans is struggling to take on
one third of the first country would
encounter on that campaign a snail
starting at the Ukrainian border with
Russia and traveling at average snail
speeds would have now overtaken the
current Russian advance and this has had
its obvious effects having so much
artillery and having it such a central
part of your Doctrine was supposed to
help Russian troops deal with enemy
threats without expending too much of
their own resources allowing them to
keep the momentum part of this was to
allow almost anyone with a working radio
the ability to call in an artillery
strike when it needed it as opposed to
the Western system where such a request
has to be run up the chain of command
now the Eastern system has been praised
because it does cut out all the red tape
and that any army men would
adamantly swear is the biggest issue the
Army faces today but of course that has
one problem if your commander rasakovich
staring down the counter-attack heading
towards your position and call it on
artillery strike you may run into the
all too common problem that said strike
is delayed because conscript idiovic
spotted something in a bush five miles
away that he thinks is the main
counter-attack and how the guns need to
be reset and this was a major problem
Russia faced during the quieter periods
any hint of a Ukrainian counter-attack
caused Russia to openly declare war on
the surrounding Countryside since
everyone can call an artillery everyone
does after all if you're facing down a
Machine Gun Nest why risk your life on
your men's life when you can summon the
artillery and while the artillery is
dealing with that half a mile down the
line your friend is being bracketed by
mortifier and has to wait you're
starting to see the problem now although
the West Western system is going to piss
off every low rank Marine who's now in
their 50s and has an opinion it means
that somewhere on that chain is someone
who is prioritizing requests on the
Russian side that isn't happening and a
great deal of time the artillery is
chasing down ghosts shooting at nothing
or being overwhelmed with confusing
requests when anything does actually
occur especially as this war has dragged
on in the Grim presence of General
paranoia on the battlefield has been
felt and this has meant increased
barrelware tired artillery men and the
heavy drain of Russia's ammo so much so
at one point the PMC Wagner group were
denied further supplies and Russia has
started to burst out increasingly older
levels of artillery in order to burn
through the different calibers of shell
it still has stockpiles of the Ukrainian
counter-offensive will follow on the
tail end of the Russian winter offensive
something we didn't even realize was
happening until it was confirmed that
yeah that clusterfucker that's actually
the winter offensive where multiple
Russian formations were wiped out
completely this is not an exaggeration
this is just what what happens when you
frontally assault well-prepared
Defenders are open terrain through a
Minefield over and over and over and
over and over again another arm of the
Russian winter offensive was around
cremina but despite the efforts of the
Russian reserve and the vdv they barely
managed to move the front lines the
situation around of divka is different
however there Russians have managed to
slowly envelop the town with Mod troops
and the inner Colonial militia as of the
making of this video the situation is
bad for ukrainians but not yet critical
should the situation turn critical
ukrainians will have to retreat to
prepare defense lines behind the town it
would not be optimal but abdifka is by
no means a strategic area as an
interesting tidbit Roundup divka Russian
mobics are being sent to DNR Colonial
brigades to be used as Skin enforter by
DNR Colonial militia officers in a
strange reverse Dynamic finally the
situation around Bak mood has received
the most attention globally bakman
itself is not important strategically
but was made relevant by both sides
concentrating tens of thousands of
troops there into what was essentially a
mead grinder politics were a large part
in build size decision Russians needed
the Victory and ukrainians did not want
to lose face by withdrawing from bakmud
but the Ukrainian decision also had a
practical side to tie down a large
number of Russian troops and draw them
into an unfavorable battle grinding them
down initial loss ratios should have
been one to five to one to seven in
favor of Ukraine with some even talking
about 1 to 15 as an absolute high this
is where thousands of Russian convicts
were forced to charge Ukrainian
positions head-on sorry if nothing else
those numbers are not impossible since
then as Russians surrounded the city on
three sides this ratio has gotten worse
to one to two one to three dead ballpark
bakmut has also been a place of
competition between the Russian mod and
Wagner both looking to claim the glory
of capturing backward for themselves
this has not happened as of the making
of this video but ukrainians seem to be
progressively pulling back now
controlling only the western parts of
town in open source intelligence circles
bokmut is often considered a failure in
Ukrainian planning needlessly grinding
down their forces that could be used for
the counter-offensive pretty
strategically insignificant town but I
don't think it's that simple Russian
propaganda has turned backmit from a
tiny underwhelming City into the single
most important battle in the history of
the Russian Federation the vatnik
propagandists want you to believe that
the entirety of Ukraine's Army is held
up there and that in a matter of days it
will become surrounded overwhelmed and
then collapse and that there is nothing
Beyond it to stop Russia sweeping across
the entire southern region of Ukraine
and finally winning the war they want
you to believe this because it distracts
from the fact that Russian Lanes haven't
moved in months and they're deploying
t-55 to the battlefield but while each
and every vatnik does their propaganda's
Duty by reporting in extremes of detail
and then jumping into round tables to
discuss the even more extremes of detail
the significant consequences for Ukraine
that the three-week-long Battle of
Bachman train station's public toilet
has had in the world that we live in the
one we call reality things aren't quite
that simple backboot is not the straw
that is going to break the Ukrainian
camel's back it is strategically
irrelevant Ukraine could lose it
tomorrow and absolutely nothing would
happen but it's been holding on to it
like losing it could cost him the war
and there's a reason for that and that
reason is oddly quite simple Ukraine is
taking heavy losses defending the city
yes but not nearly as many as Russia is
attempting to take it with Russian
losses estimated as being up to 30 times
that of Ukraine Ukraine is also able to
cycle its troops in and out of the city
approximately 25
000 soldiers sit in the region
surrounding Bachman and take it in turns
defending the city cycling about 5 000
troops in and out every three days or so
Russia cannot do this for relatively
little risk Ukraine is bleeding Russia
of its resources because bagmet has
become such a focal point for Russian
propaganda the Russian forces cannot
withdraw if they do the blow to Russian
morale would be devastating politically
it would destroy careers and it might
even start to turn the tide of public
favor against the war so it has no
choice it must keep pounding away at
bakmit spending what little it has left
trying to take a strategically
meaningless Target because of this up
session with bakmit Russia lacks the
resources to go on the offensive so for
the time being it must play ball it must
sit behind its lines and wait for
Ukraine to make the first move because
it's not taking back mid that's going to
be the problem it's what happens next
and this takes us to the Ukrainian
summer counter-offensive Ukraine has
been training and accumulating tubes
behind the front lines for months now
incorporating more modern Western
Hardware into its formations Bradley's
Martyrs leopard twos Strikers
Challengers mraps and training tens of
thousands of troops for professional
Maneuvers all this will be put up
against Russia's aging increasingly
obsolete hardware and badly trained
mobics that being said let's not forget
that holding defensive lines is much
less difficult than conducting
large-scale combined art Maneuvers on
the other hand defending against a
large-scale Ukrainian offensive is also
more difficult than just trapping AKs
into mobik's hands and telling them to
go sit in a trench somewhere Defenders
need to be coordinated and constantly
organized artillery needs to be adjusted
Ukrainian Maneuvers need to be monitored
as for ukrainians despite their
advantage in equipment and Troop quality
things can get really tough especially
if we consider the large network of
trenches built by the Russians and the
artillery and minefields that accompany
them this will not be an easy going for
Ukraine even with all their new modern
restaurant equipment having the best
tanks the best equipment the best
training is all good and well so long as
you never have to actually use them as
you could have the latest
gravity-defying dual barrel 3D prints
its own ammo hover tank that every idiot
sci-fi concept artist draws because they
saw the aat from Star Wars when they
were 12. but if you don't have the feel
for them if you can't get that fuel to
the front lines if you lack the spare
parts if your tanks need to rely on
driving themselves from one side of the
country to the other if you can't
recover damaged tanks from the
battlefield if you can't maintain them
if you don't have the spare parts then
it doesn't matter how powerful these
tanks are they are going to be next to
useless that is Ukraine's current
problem in theory right now they have
the equipment the men and the resources
to attack every single point along the
entire line and Russia would be
extremely Limited in its ability to
respond but what Ukraine lacks is the
ability to keep up that momentum a
supply Lane start to stretch any delay
any point where their forces get bogged
down and fighting if Russian forces
decide to dig in or the defenses were
more formidable than anticipate it or
their response faster the offense runs
the risk of petering out and becomes
vulnerable to counter-attack as guns run
out of ammo tanks run out of fuel and
Men become exhausted Ukraine may have
Western Equipment but it does not have
the supply to do what western Nations do
but the good news is it doesn't have to
Russian Supply problems have become
significantly more problematic than
expected and are happening a lot faster
than many experts believed prior to this
war Russia declared it had very few
t-55s left and what it had were in
museums neither on the front lines
Russia's need for replacement equipment
is so great it has brought three new
factories online for the purposes of
refurbishing old equipment left in
storage the priority being tanks of
which 800 have been earmarked for refurb
of which the factory claims will take it
three years those 800 tanks are not t90s
or t80s or even Russia's Workhorse the
t-72 they are t-62s and to supply those
with the fuel enamel they need they are
still killing civilian Vehicles every
day Russia is getting weaker every day
it loses more than it can afford to
replace experienced men are being
replaced by the quickly or the untrained
and many of those lack basic equipment
outside of assault rifles they lack
medical supplies and sleep rough I know
originally this was a problem just for
the DNR which is basically an armed
militia Russia supplies with weapons and
has spread to secondary fronts rear
guard positions and now we're starting
to see evidence of it on the front lines
Ukraine has time Russia does not so it
can set and wait for as long as it wants
with the Ukrainian country offensive we
are in uncharted waters somewhat it will
be unlike other country offensives we've
seen so far like in horkie for herzl
this time the enemy is better prepared
and has more or less intact supply lines
despite their supply problems now will
there be any game-changing weapons
involved on the Ukrainian side like the
high bar system was last summer one
example is the glsdb or ground launch
small diameter bomb which Ukraine is
bound to get it has a range of 150
kilometers about twice that of high Mars
that Ukraine could use to force Russian
Supply Depots backward causing supply
lines to collapse as good as it sounds I
don't think the glsdb will have any
meaningful effect on the counter
offensive it's available in very limited
quantities with no mass production yet
so even if Ukraine got them there is not
much they can accomplish with it the
other wanted game-changing weapon is the
otter comes atacms a high Mars launch
rocket with a range of 300 kilometers
but the US will likely not deliver these
in the name of the escalation though I
wish they did as for the Western
Equipment that has been delivered the
Bradley's the striker the leopards and
so on they will have a positive effect
on the counter-offensive obviously
though the bulk of the Ukrainian force
is still made up of Soviet era Hardware
so what will happen during the
counter-offensive where will Ukraine
strike and what will be the results it's
a tough question but here are some ideas
Ukraine's two options are basically the
South runs uprogia and the East around
cremina or bug mode some people suggest
that Harrison is also at play but I find
the massive amphibious Cross River
result unlikely so first off the
potential offensive in the East
ukrainians have been conducting a
counter-offensive around criminal before
the Russian winter offensive so their
summer offensive could be a continuation
of that if so their goal would be to
take sautovia and starobils cutting a
very important Russian rail supply line
and severing other important Road
Connections at that point ukrainians
could push all the way to the 2014 line
of demarcation possibly further now then
the potential offensive in the South
everyone has been talking about it for
months now so what can we expect the
south is very important for Russia
because currently that's their primary
Lifeline to Crimea The Carriage Bridge
still isn't fully restored and is
impassable for large heavy freight
trains Russia depends on rail above all
when it comes to Logistics and trains to
Crimea have to run through the South
specifically through the town of tokmok
which is precariously close to the front
line to itself there is many people
where the only major road connection to
Crimea passes if ukrainians managed to
take these two towns every Russian
soldier in Harrison and Crimea will be
effectively cut off from most supplies
The Carriage Bridge and the adjacent
fairies simply couldn't cope with the
volume currently transported VIA Rail
even worse for Russians if ukrainians
push down all the way to the Sea they
will be within 150 kilometers of the
Carriage Bridge and would likely render
it impossible Crimea would be
effectively isolated with every Russian
in it such a scenario would likely cause
Panic among the local population and we
could see a chaotic Rush towards the
carriage Ferry akin to the evacuation of
Afghanistan if ukrainians disable the
cash bridge I should stress so this
should put Russian defenses in the South
into perspective while those lines of
trenches and minefields are formidable
at the end of the day they are the only
thing standing between Ukraine and the
isolation of Crimea so will Ukraine
attack in the South or in the East we
can only speculate here but if I had to
bet on it I would put my money on
ukrainians attacking at least on two
fronts creating a dilemma for the
Russians you can either reinforce the
east or the South if you reinforce the
East the South Falls if you reinforce
the South the East Falls and I believe
the outcome of the Ukrainian summer
counter offensive will dictate the
outcome of the war depending on the
level of Ukrainian success the bad
ending would be the offensive bogging
down Ukraine exhausting itself and
Russians forcing a stalemate the Ukraine
war turns into a frozen conflict Ukraine
is left in limbo and Russia may or may
not start preparing for a second try as
things stand now this is rather unlikely
the okay ending would be the Ukrainian
counter-offensive being more successful
than not making important gains but
there are no dramatic developments that
would shift the course of the war too
much in this scenario significant
territories are liberated but Russia
also keeps a sizable chunk including
Crimea at that point possibly a
settlement is negotiated borders are
redrawn and Ukraine joins nato in the
ear the war ends with Ukraine safe from
any future Russia aggression I think
this is a possible scenario the good
ending would be a successful Ukrainian
counter-offensive cutting Russian supply
lines in the South disabling The
Carriage Bridge and sending Russian
forces into disarray Ukraine then grinds
down the remaining cut off Russian
troops and restores his territorial
Integrity the war ends and Ukraine joins
NATO and the EU I think this is also a
possible outcome though for now less so
than the okay ending for now my money is
on the okay ending which is only okay in
terms of our maximum goals that is the
good ending I think even that okay
ending would be a pretty damn good
outcome for Ukraine they will have
retained their independence joined the
EU and NATO and can start rebuilding
Russia on the other hand had destroyed
its Army and Global reputation and
ruined itself economically for a few
insignificant territorial gains now a
question on many people's minds could be
in response to potentially losing the
war and also Crimea would rush a nuke my
answer to that is no if Russia was
serious about its nuclear threats they
would have nuked long ago instead their
red lines have been shifting constantly
they said Russia will use nukes to
protect its territory then the annexed
hairzone making it part of Russia
ukrainians then took back here soon but
no nukes flew they said Russia would use
nukes to protect Crimea Ukraine has been
bombing Crimea on a regular bases and
blew to catch Bridge and yet new nukes
flew they said Russia will use nukes if
Ukraine gets modern Western tanks you
crinkled the tanks but once again new
nukes were launched to be honest I'm not
even sure Russia has enough working
nuclear weapons to wage a nuclear war at
this point nuclear weapons need a lot of
expensive maintenance and the easiest
way to save money is on maintenance
looking at the rest of their military
all the corruption the lack of
Maintenance and all the non-functioning
equipment it's really not a far-fetched
idea that the same happened to their
nuclear forces added to the fact that
we're now past the 10th Russia nuclear
red line with nothing happening and well
you might just start having doubts about
Russia nuclear capability so this was my
update on the Ukrainian
counter-offensive featuring The One and
Only laser pin do check out laser picks
Channel his content is great especially
his videos about Russian tanks I've also
put a list of trusted accounts in the
description that you can follow and get
accurate information about the war in
Ukraine thank you for watching and I'll
be seeing you next time just in time my
voice is starting to go out